okay so now we've learned about what
automatic dlp is we've configured it and
it's running creating our data profiles
now we get to the fun part analyzing the
results
welcome to another video about automatic
data loss prevention or dlp if you
haven't been following along check out
this playlist for our earlier videos
data is only as good as the insights
you're able to get from it and
oftentimes we have the data we can see
it
but we have to do a lot of work to
actually get to those useful insights
thankfully automatic dlp has a few easy
ways to write and consume the results of
your scans
you can use the console publish to
chronicle export profiles to bigquery
which will allow you to run sql queries
and visualize the profiles in data
studio and publish notifications to pub
sub
let's touch on each of these a little
deeper and take a look at some examples
the simplest way to consume your data is
right in the console
so once you save your configuration
click on the profiles tab and your
information is right there in the table
here you can see your bigquery assets
and filter by projects data sets and
tables you can also click on a specific
table to see the full table profile
along with a list of all the column
profiles for that table
also included are links to access logs
iim recommendations access lists and
more
publishing to chronicle is a powerful
feature that can bring your sensitive
data insights into your security
operations to enrich your threat
detection investigation and response
the chronicle platform allows security
teams to cost effectively store and
analyze all their security data in one
place to investigate and detect threats
at speed and scale
by sending your data to chronicle you're
enhancing your security operations and
improving your overall posture
to use this feature chronicle must be
enabled for your organization
you can also choose to export your data
to bigquery this will allow you access
to your data in its raw form but in a
queryable format you can write sql
queries against it or load the data into
a third-party tool of your choice
to export your data profiles to bigquery
you'll need the project id data set id
and table id of the table where you want
the profiles to be exported to let's
call this the output table
i created a project lovely lion data set
and table in bigquery before this so
i'll use that here
okay so now we save and we can go check
out our results in bigquery
when automatic dlp exports data profiles
to your output table it also creates the
latest view this view is a pre-filtered
virtual table that includes only the
latest snapshots of your data profiles
the output table contains all the older
snapshots of the data profile in case
you want to see change history or keep
an audit
the latest view has the same schema as
the output table so you can choose the
two interchangeably
the query results will differ though
because the output table contains
historical data
okay now let's check our data
i want to query my data set for person
names to do that i select the table i
want demo table 1
and click query
i'll delete the first line and then put
in a sample query you can find some of
these sample queries in the
documentation
customize the sample query to use the
table you want to query
in this case i'm actually going to go
with the latest view table
and then click run
the results appear and there you can see
every table across my organization that
has a column containing person names
org level scans will pull from all
projects in the org so you'll see my
project lovely lion and the other
projects that my colleagues have made
so that is how you can query your data
by publishing two bigquery from dlp
having the power of bigquery enables you
to analyze the data however you need it
also means you can create visual
dashboards and reports and tools like
data studio or looker
to get you started we provided a
pre-made as in made for you data studio
report that highlights the rich insights
of your data
data studio is a report generation tool
that enables users to easily visualize
their data
you can use this pre-made report as is
or you can customize it as needed
to view the pre-made report with your
data enter the required values for
project id data set id and table or view
id in the following url
then copy the resulting url to your
browser for the purpose of showing you
the best dashboard possible i'm going to
use some more robust data than the test
data that i put in my data set and this
is what it will look like when you have
all your data loaded
the automatic data profiler dashboard is
a multi-page report that gives you a
quick high-level view of your data
profiles including breakdowns by risk by
info type and by location
and you can explore the other tabs to
drill down to specific metrics like
regional summary
and advanced exploration
this allows you to quickly see answers
to specific questions like do i have pii
in europe
cool
and if you do want to create a custom
report with your data you can
check out the documentation in the
description for instructions
another option is to publish to pub sub
this option lets you provide pub sub
topics to send notifications about and
when to send those notifications
like when a table is reprofiled or when
the risk or sensitivity score of a table
increases
you choose what criteria will generate a
notification and whether the
notification should include just the
affected table's resource name or the
full table profile
these alerts will make you aware of any
possible risk in your data as soon as
it's found so that you can take
necessary actions quickly
now you can see why automatic dlp allows
you to easily get rich insights from
your data with the options we've
discussed you can now look at your data
in a more in-depth way than previously
possible and these features expand
opportunities for you and your business
make sure you check out the links in the
description for documentation and in our
next video we'll talk about what to do
with your findings to remediate issues
and mitigate risk
thanks for watching
you